Let's talk about URLs. undoubtedly, you've seen
URLs before. URL stands for Uniform Resource Locator.
An example of URL would be as follows. This is an example of URL. It's
got three main parts. It's got the protocol, separated by a column and two
slashes from the host. Which precedes the path and in this case the path is just
a slash and if we didn't have that slash there the
path would still be a slash because that's the, the minimum path.
Now, the protocol can be a number of things but for
our purposes it's going to be http almost all the time. We will
also see https from time to time. And you'll see other
protocols around the web. You might see ftp or you know, things,
things like that, but http basically means, you know, the web.
That's, that's what we're going to be learning in this class. The host,
this is the host name or domain name of the, of
the server that has the document we want to access. This
can also be an IP address. This host just of course,
translates into an IP address, and this is the. You know, the
description of the location of the physical machine that has the
document we want to fetch. And the path is the document
we're going to fetch. Now, the path can be more complicated.
So the path would be this whole thing if we were accessing
the image we were using in the previous part of the lecture.